what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so what are the things that I love so
much about DC rebirth is that it's
really going back to like the roots of
what made a lot of these characters so
popular and it's really kind of going
back in a lot of ways as far back as the
pre-crisis on Infinite Earths roots when
it came to these characters and this is
more so than when it comes to the Titans
themselves the reason why I say that is
because remember and the previous video
we talked about realest Titans vol 1 and
even during you know Titans rebirth we
had talked about how in a lot of ways
the Titans themselves were rooted in the
teen titans eot Titans go all the way
back to before crisis on Infinite Earths
they were basically the sidekicks of DC
superhero lineup coming together as a
team and then fighting different
villains it was a great way for DC to
kind of you know give teenagers their
own little piece of the pie it was a
great way for them to give their own
little niche and say hey this book was
made just for you you can read anything
else you want to but this book was
written exclusively for you it's not
designed for adults and because of that
teens loved at the Teen Titans that it
became about became a mainstay in fact
there was a point in DC college
landscape when the Teen Titans were
actually the highest selling publication
they had they out sold everything else
including Justice League Superman Batman
and that's you know the Justice League
Superman and Batman at the height of
their popularity that just shows you
really how popular this team was but as
time progressed and the Teen Titans went
through various iterations and DC
started to move into the newer and in
darker landscape over the post-crisis on
Infinite Earths you know after the death
of Gwen Stacy in 1971 going into the
whole you know post Dark Knight Returns
era of Kali books the original Teen
Titans went away and they were
transformed or kind of brought back into
the Titans the problem with this was
that when DC's lost the new 52 the
Titans were nowhere to be seen with the
exception of Titans hunt all you had was
just the newest version of Teen Titans
and fans didn't really care for that
team too much because it was so far
removed from the team that they were
familiar with and it really left out a
lot of the members did they had come to
identify with and so because of this
with regards to this one shot and really
with the first volume of Teen Titans the
first story arc of of Titans in in DC
Comics it's a return to familiarity now
the cool thing about this is dan admits
it Stanton says okay guys here's the
deal we basically have the Titans
fighting some guy now in a normal
circumstances we could just kind of
write this off and just say hey they're
just fighting a guy with metahuman
powers but the cool thing about this is
again dan Abbott is setting things up
he's basically saying hey this guy
basically got metahuman powers for the
first time someone gave them to him and
the way we know this is because of the
kind of things he's saying you know hey
I've
menace I got menace stuff you know just
really know what his powers are called
what the technical term is you know he's
talking about how he can grow to a huge
size he even refers to the Titans as the
Justice League now the reason why we
know this guy's brand new to the scene
is that historically speaking in DC
Comics it's kind of like this unwritten
rule and even in Marvel Comics it's kind
of this unwritten rule that when a new
legitimate villain you know pops up onto
the scene that is to say a bad guy
that's probably gonna be a mainstay for
a little while he knows who all the
superhero teams are you know or she
knows who all the superhero teams are
they know who the x-men are they know
who the Avengers are that kind of thing
it's just an unwritten rule it's written
that way for the sake of us having to
really question the the suspension of
disbelief you know we just kind of take
it as an absolute yeah like yeah you
know he knows as they are the fact that
this guy has no idea who the Titans are
tells us that this guy is relatively new
to the superhero community the Titans
are somewhat of the new Reformation you
know but the idea is that they're
closely intertwined with a Justice
League you know they're closely
intertwined with some of the most
notable superheroes and DC Comics and so
most everybody knows who they are now
something else that I also want you to
take note of here is there's a lot of
banter back and forth between Roy Harper
and Donna Troy again Donna Troy is a
character that has a very very confusing
history but she was a lot of ways tied
to the origin of Wonder Woman and while
she has changed over the years she is
part and parcel very similar to Wonder
Woman in terms of how she fights how she
looks so on and so forth as far as I can
tell from the direction this story's
going in they're actually gonna come
back and create like a definitive origin
for her character and so I don't want to
touch on that too much I actually want
to have that discussion once they get
around to her new origin presuming that
that happens if it doesn't that what
kind of touch on that later on but one
of the most interesting aspects of Donna
Troy and Roy Harper is that for a long
time DC always had the two of them just
kind of getting together you know they
were just one of these these power
couples so to speak in DC it really goes
all the way back to 1967 in a lot of
ways of the original Teen Titans run I
mean back then the stories weren't
nearly as like adult oriented as they
were later on down the line but it was
always something incoming books like Ann
in comics you always have heroes they
just pair up you know they just come
together it's just you know they all
just kind of pair off and they go their
own separate ways and for Roy Harper and
Donna Troy was always you know the two
of them kind of you know will they won't
they that sort of thing but they've had
like disastrous dates and that's kind of
the cool thing here is we basically get
to see this or I just kind of relive
this like disastrous date between the
two of them but it comes out to be kind
of romantic it actually comes out to be
pretty cute but the other funny thing
about this this is what I love about Dan
Abnett writing is that after they to
feed this bad guy there
is kind of talking about what's going on
and where Harper's kind of being like
the the jerk of the team which is one of
the reasons why we love him so much but
the group's met with the arrival of
Superman and the reason why this is so
cool is because this creates
cohesiveness I mean when we sit down and
we read you know Justice League or we
read Superman and we read Batman or some
like that so far in DC rebirth it's been
all the teams taking care of problems on
their own it's been then you know then
them just being like hey we can't call
on the Justice League because we're busy
we see that degree and lanterns all the
time you know just recruiters of Simon
Baz one of them will be like why don't
we just call the Justice League we're a
member of the team why don't we just
call them and it's like well they're all
off doing their own thing in fact
there's been stories where heroes do
contact the Justice League and everybody
in the Justice League is busy I think
that was a Batman story but it's just a
way for DC to say hey here's their first
story arcs
this is them just kind of focusing on
their own with Superman coming in with
Superman saying hey look I heard about a
commotion in in in New York I showed up
here but you guys have everything
already taken care of it's cool because
one is Superman sitting down and saying
hey you guys are legit you guys are
legit team you guys are awesome you know
the other half of this is is DC sitting
down and saying hey Superman and the
Justice a they're not oblivious to
everything that goes on it's not like
some team it's fighting a villain and
the Justice they just have no idea
what's happening Superman just kind of
happen to be around and just saw what
was going on decided to step in and then
everything was over but the other cool
thing about this and a truth I think the
best thing about this story is that we
have two three new 52 characters and
what this story does this is what I love
about this there's a lot of confusion
out there people ask me a lot about
what's going on how do we tie in Wally
West in the pre new 52 suit rant with a
new 42 right now how do we reconcile
those universes I don't understand
what's going on three new 52 new 52 I
don't I don't get everything that's on
this that's going on here
this comic seems to set the stage for
how all that's getting reconciled and
and we'll get to that you know once we
cross that bridge but the cool thing is
that Superman recognizes Wally West he
knows who he is because remember the pre
new 52 Superman sits down and he could
basically came from the pre flashpoint
area flashpoint being the story that
initiated DC's new 52 relaunch in a suit
ran this version comes before all that
this is the classic Superman that we all
know and love and so because of this ah
you know he's like Wally I know who you
are and so Wally has no idea who he is
doesn't know what's going on with this
guy and so Wally Wally basically races
off now this is when Dan Abnett kind of
toys with us for a little bit this is
when Dan Abnett you know plays a few
games here and there but the overall
idea seems to be that the two of them
basically just kind of race off and it
provides this really cool situation
where it's like you know who gets there
first now the cool thing is Superman
basically says you're faster than I
remember you know it's really kind of
Superman at least it seems to be him
saying hey you're faster than I am you
know now the funny thing about this too
is that Wally West is like who are you I
don't know who you are I don't know
what's going on here now this is where I
say DC and dad Amanat are kind of toying
with us because the whole situation what
they're basically offering here at least
it seems to be what they're suggesting
is that when the new 52 first launched
in 2011 it was a wholly new universe
prior to the new 52 you had the DC line
of comics and then you had the vertigo
line of comics which dealt with like
angels demons Ezra he found Lucifer and
that's where he really found that the
best stories of Constantine the
Hellblazer
and then you had Wildstorm which is a
whole other imprint in and of itself ah
DC had the main publications and then
vertigo and wild storm were really just
kind of those that were intertwined with
DC and they would cross over when the
new 52 launched all three of those
publications were merged into one single
universes so now it was all taking place
at the same time and because of that it
created this whole new you like new 52
universe well what seems to be happening
here is Superman between the
conversation the Superman and Wally West
are saying when they're talking about
somebody going through an editing time
different things like that what seems to
be happening here is DC say no no no no
no you know they're going back to the
changing it and say okay we said the new
52 was a new universe when we first
launched it that's not true that's not
what happened what happened was the
flash Barry Allen went back in time
saved his mom's life initiated the
flashpoint event went back kept himself
from saving his mom's life tried to set
everything back to normal and when he
did somebody stepped in and did
something now we're assuming it's dr.
Manhattan where we're taking the
assumption here in DC rebirth that
between the time that Barry Allen did
what he did in flashpoint the moment
between everything started you know
everything started to go back to normal
in the new 52 was launched the doctor
man hadn't stepped in and said okay this
is what we're gonna do we're gonna edit
we're gonna go through his hard editing
you know the universe or something like
that we don't really know what it is
that he did but the end result is that
because of his actions we picked up with
a new 52
superheroes had just appeared for the
very first time that
and so again what seems to have actually
happened what's what do you see what dan
Abbott seems to be saying here is that
the new 52 it was created by dr.
Manhattan instead what was supposed to
happen was Barry Allen went back in time
saved his mom's life basically initiated
the flashpoint universe realized that he
had screwed everything up went back in
time stopped himself from saving his
mom's life and then everything was
supposed to go back to normal but
instead
dr. Manhattan stepped in screw stuff up
now yeah I'm just grabbing this from a
few words here and there that these
characters are saying I may be entirely
wrong about this I could be wrong on so
many levels but that seems to be the
direction things are going and again we
won't really know until Jeff John Rice
Watchmen until dr. Manhattan is full-on
revealed in the DC as part of DC rebirth
you know until we see this massive you
know comic that just says hey everybody
here's exactly what happened which by
the way I am excited for when for
whatever that story happens to be
whatever it gets released because you
know it will I'm so excited for that ah
but the other cool thing about this is
keep in mind this this is why I say Dan
Abnett is is one of the best writers
when it comes to Superman yeah Curt Swan
had a 30-year run on Superman but I
think that Dan Abnett has it has a great
take on the character Wally West the
Prine if he did see Wally West sits down
and says nothing's like I remember it I
mean yeah okay if you remember me that's
cool you know what I was like do you
remember how things worked but he says I
don't like nothing's the way it was
myself Linda Park who of course was his
wife before the events of new 52 he says
this Linda Park doesn't know me she
doesn't know who I am and Superman says
yeah things are different for me than
they are for you I mean I I still have
Lois Lane I have a son my personal life
is intact everything that I knew before
the new 52 when it came to Lois Lane so
on and so forth that's all still there
but he says for you Wally West you're
basically starting over again you're
essentially starting brand-new but it's
great because if Linda Park as you know
her now her personality is exactly like
that Linda Park that you knew before the
new 52 happen because rumors they don't
want Wally West knows about about Barry
Allen I don't believe that Superman
knows about the flashpoint event but
when he what he says you know everything
that you knew before all that if that
Linda Park is the exact same if their
personalities are the same the only
difference is she doesn't know who you
are then it's time to fight for that
it's time to fight for the life that you
want and be happy and that's the coolest
thing about this that's that's the
coolest thing about Superman because
what he's doing he's imparting these old
man's Superman
words of wisdom where he's basically
saying life's too short to not be happy
you know and Wally West knows this Wally
West should know this because remember
the entire first story art of the Titans
was Wally West figuring out why everyone
didn't know he existed you know of
course we knew it was the villain
abra-cadaver who basically you know used
his powers to white Wally West from the
minds of the world but for Wally West
he should know because he's basically
been a dead man for the entirety of the
new 52 run so far you know he wasn't
dead dead you know per se but the world
didn't know he was there and so we might
as well have been dead and so because of
that you know he should have a better
idea better than most about how precious
and how valuable life is and so he
should know that if that if he cares
about this version of Linda Park he's
got to go fight for that he's got to go
step out and say look you don't know me
I know you're not the Linda Park that I
knew you don't know me but let's go out
and get dinner sometime that's that's
that's what should happen that's exactly
how we should play out and that's how it
did play out and that's why it works so
well is because it's Superman giving
these little pieces of advice to a
superhero that we've all come to know
and love now transitioning over to Donna
Troy this is why I say things get kind
of cool here because you're basically in
midtown Manhattan and they're at a diner
the way this originally played out at
least as far as far as I can tell hum if
I'm correct about this the way though
the way it originally played out with
Donna Troy and Roy Harper the first date
they went on was disastrous because the
arrow mo Bo the arrow car that Roy
Harper was driving was like it was
basically Jack somebody jacked the car
that he was driving on it kind of led to
it you know some some funny situations
in terms of the two of them getting
together sharing a kiss that kind of
thing but this very much seems to be the
case it really seems to be Dan and it's
sitting down and saying these two were
getting together now the reason why this
works so well is because Roy Harper man
he's he's spitting some mad game on her
like like he said he spent some mad game
on on Donna Troy but it also works out
because Roy Harper's a guy who's been
through some things you know I mean when
it comes to his character assuming that
that you know what we believe is correct
with the fact that his memories have
been altered that eventually his
memories will be restored and he'll be
like I remember in my whole life you
know with light all that kind of good
stuff he's been through a lot of things
Donna Troy is the exact same way these
two are basically hard-asses you know
they're about as tough as it gets and to
see the two of them just kind of let
their guard down even if it's only for a
night and Roy Harper just starts
spitting game and he starts acting you
know kidneys flirting with Donna Troy it
works out because we know the two of the
are gonna start getting together now now
the other half of this is again you know
the two of them are really talking about
Donna Troy's pass they're talking about
her past life you know talking about her
really in a lot of ways confusion about
where she comes from what her origin
story is so on so it really seems to be
Dan Abnett kind of dancing around this
idea that yes we'll get into the origin
of Donna Troy somewhere along the line
but again he sets the stage for what's
to come when we're basically introduced
to a guy named Simon now Simon as far as
I can tell is a wholly new creation by
Dan Abnett he's never existed before but
he's basically running a company called
meta solutions and the idea seems to be
that they're basically giving metahuman
powers to normal people or waking up
metahuman powers that they already have
which one it is
I'm not a hundred percent sure the way
the people are talking here the way this
couple is talking anyway they're talking
about waking up metahuman powers and so
it may be that metahuman solutions that
are meta solutions of saying hey you all
have powers you don't come here and I'll
wake you know will wake them up whereas
in truth they're actually just giving
them powers they didn't have before but
it really seems to be setting the stage
for hey you know what are the Titans
gonna do against a company that's
basically just giving out meta powers to
people you know with no real question on
whether they deserve them or not but the
way the Dan Abnett basically wraps this
issue out is beautifully done in a sense
that we essentially just just pick up
with a revelation that tightness tower
is being recreated the Titans tower has
been remade now the reason why this is
so cool is because Titans Tower is like
the Titans own version of the Justice
League Watchtower you know it's their
own little base of operations because at
this point they're just kind of been
operating out of an apartment building
which as cool as that may be everybody's
just kind of being roommates on you know
living in the same space and just
operating a head of an apartment
building and truth we really need them
to have their own base of operations
because what it does is it gives
legitimacy it says okay they're not some
you know some ramshackle team now you
know they're not just kind of living on
a shoestring these this team is a
legitimate tried and true superhero team
they've arrived they are here now and is
it is cool because it basically means
that a lot of the Titans mythos really a
lot of like the Teen Titans mythos is
really starting to come back it's really
starting to really reform itself and it
starting to structure to the point of DC
rebirth where a lot of the things that
we all knew before the new 52 you are
really starting to come more cohesive
they're really starting to become become
solid again but if you guys are new here
to come as explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob Court if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all inner peace
[Music]